في الثلاثين من حزيران عام 98 قرر المدعي
العام البولندي سكارجيسكو كمينه الذي كان
يتولى عددا كبيرا من قضايا المافيا البقاء
في وقت اضافي في مكتبه لمتابعه مباراه
الارجنتين وانجلترا في مونديال فرنسا كان
على كمين ان يتوجه الى المحكمه في سيارته
الرسميه لكن جاذبيه المونديال غيرت
اولوياته في ذلك النهار تبع كمينا 90
دقيقه مثيره انتهت بالتعادل بهدفين
لمثلهما قبل ان يحل ربطه عنقه للاستمتاع
بالاشواط الاضافيه لكن في الشوط الاضافي
الثاني اهتز مكتته بسبب انفجار وقع في
مراه مجمع المحاكم لقد كانت محاوله اغتيار
تستهدفه بزرع قنبله في سيارته انقذ شغف
المدعي العام البولندي بالمونديال وكره
القدم حياته بل يمكن القول انما انقذ
حياته فشل منتخبي الارجنتيني وانجلترا في
حسني ميزالهما في الوقت الاصلي للقاء